comme on vient de le voir et de
l'entendre la canoéiste laurence vincent
lapointe est sous choc
l'annoncé de sa suspension elle la vit
très mal tout comme le fait d'être
désormais associée à une histoire de
dopage allons tout de suite en parler
avec l'incontournable christiane ayotte
directrice du laboratoire de contrôle du
dopage de l'ineris institut armand
frappier bonsoir madame ayotte
alors dans ces jo spécifiant que c'est
votre laboratoire qui a procédé au test
vous savez donc un athlète anonyme si on
veut avait eu un test antidopage positif
en juillet vous ignoriez qu'il
s'agissait de laurence ces dons un peu
comment tout se passe en coulisse
l'écouter c'est totalement totalement
inconnu l'identité des athlètes pour de
bonnes raisons ça sur l'objectivité du
processus donc les échantillons d'urines
sont recueillies auprès de l'athlète
s'est envoyé dans un laboratoire le nom
autres en l'instance il s'agissait de
tests hors compétition à l'improviste
diligenté par la fédération
internationale de canots et les
échantillons qu'aux dégâts que des codes
sont envoyés au laboratoire alors dans
un premier temps on analyse
l'échantillon à
on trouve une substance interdite elle
doit être confirmée
une fois tout le processus analytique
fait on rend un certificat et la
l'athlète est informée à ce moment là
donc comme ça a été expliqué ce matin
l'athlète droit de demander la contre
expertise de l'échantillon b
et c'est ce qui s'est également pas
assez et parlons de ces substances
brièvement la ligue en roll donc cette
substance qui étaient décidées dans son
organisme qu'est ce qu'on doit savoir
là-dessus madame ayotte le ligand drôle
c'est une pour moi c'est une catastrophe
que ça circule de façon aussi claire on
peut même en trouver sur amazon il faut
bien voir que ce sont des produits qui
sont pas homologuées ce et des
médicaments dont santé canada met un
garde
les consommateurs ne veulent pas nous
suggère pas de consommer ces produits là
sur la base de données préliminaires on
dit que ce produit là pourraient être
associés que c'est un sari les mêmes
effets qu'un anabolisants comme la
testostérone au stanozolol sans aucun
des effets secondaires donc ce qui
arrive c'est la même chose que pour les
drogues ou les a payés de les feintes à
lille par exemple c'est synthétiser en
chine
ça c'est importé par des gens qui le met
en bouteille ici qui met une étiquette
et qui le vendent leur vendre d'après ça
et ça peut-être pris peut-être aussi de
façon en fait sans le savoir à l'insu
des athlètes il ya toutes sortes de cas
de figure je me dois de vous poser la
question en fait de vous relancer sur un
aspect de la conférence de presse
aujourd'hui de l'athlète en question qui
dit mettez ferait partie d'un centre
national d'entraînement je
m'approvisionne auprès de ce centre là
pour mes supplément ce centre l'un lui
sa prise approvisionne auprès d'une
compagnie qui selon toute vraisemblance
sur les normes de la diligence mondiale
antidopage
il est où le problème dans la chaîne il
ya quelque chose qui se perd en quelque
part mais c'est sérieux deux choses il
ya plusieurs choses en fait du ligand
drôle ça peut se retrouver n'importe où
ça peut se retrouver
s'il y en a eu dans la chaîne de
production
aussi c'est fabriqué dans un endroit où
on manipule du ligand drôle c'est la
même chose pour les noix la fabriquer
danger
dans une entreprise qui pour qu'ils
utilisent des noix ou si c'est la même
chose donc supplément qui provient d'un
fournisseur qui a aucun contact avec le
ligand drôle ça ne peut pas être
contaminé
durant le processus de fabrication de
manufacture et de distribution alors à
ce moment là on dirait que la
contamination peut avoir eu lieu après
maintenant qu'est-ce que centre
d'entraînement fait dans la distribution
de suppléments aux athlètes
moi personnellement ça me fait tiquer
par contre ils peuvent se dire que comme
les athlètes se sont fait laver le
cerveau et croit qu'il est indispensable
de consommer des suppléments qui sont
des suppléments qui s'en moquent
contiennent pas de substances interdites
là à ce moment là ils doivent se dire
vaut mieux que ça soit nous qui offrions
ces suppléments aux athlètes et nous
nous assurerons que ces suppléments ont
été testés de façon convenable au canada
et aux états unis
on recommande les ligues
professionnelles c'est la même chose ne
recommande que des suppléments des
produits sportifs qui aurait été testé
par une compagnie donné qu'on sait est
suffisamment sérieuse et qui teste pour
la batterie de produits donc c'est un
milieu qui est complète le milieu est
très complexe sportif et ça laisse en
son garde l'impression finalement que
c'est impossible de tout contrôler que
quiconque peut se faire prendre par un
produit à son insu en quelque part on va
terminer ainsi qu'en pensez vous mais
non cela il faut il faut pas faire peur
aux athlètes le si les athlètes font
attention à la source des produits
qu'ils consomment
il ne devrait pas avoir de problèmes aux
l'athlète est l'ultime responsable de ce
qui vient dans son corps ce qui est un
ski est essentielle voilà ce que râperie
donc cet athlète à ses dépens pour la
suite mais ce sera sa défense qu'il
faudrait échafaudé merci beaucoup madame
ayotte au revoir au revoir